check out this uh this tweet from Wall
Street Silver on Twitter coming to a
town near you face scanning for Access
oh I saw this and public transportation
it works great as long as your social
credit score is high enough because you
obey fire and then there's another video
I don't know if you saw Tick Tock where
a woman says she's paying her bills at
Whole Foods her check out with her Palm
what okay it's like a RFID chip or a
bank account you go up to a machine and
you put your credit card in it you then
hold your hand over it and it scans your
hand and then you take your card out and
now your hand print is is connected to
your card so when when you're buying
your groceries is that Whole Foods I
think it was you walk up and you just
hold your hand over the thing goes and
then you walk right out no I want this
not at all I don't want any piece of
this I recently I moved out of New York
and part of it was like I don't want
this encroaching you know overtaking of
my body and soul and mind and identity
to like go to all of this stuff we're
very close to New York to having the
thing where you put your hand scanner on
just to ride the subway that's what this
is no no have you seen Minority Report
no when uh you've never seen Minority
Report come on dunkers he walks into
only watch space movies and stoner
comedies and like yeah it's the future
he gets an eye he hits eye implants
you know for I guess um your eyes they
recognize they can all the cameras
everywhere scan your eyes so he gets
them removed and gets other eyes put in
and then he like he walks into a mall
and it's like hello Mr Wong and then the
ads like because it's like Mr Wong's
eyes or whatever are all tailored to him
so you're walking around seeing things
man they'll be like hi Libby did you
pick up that new lipstick yet it's right
over here around the corner that's what
it's going to be like they're doing this
facial recognition stuff
I went to a few years ago the uh it was
the the Amazon store I think it was in
in Seattle yeah where they have a store
yeah you walk in they walk out grab
whatever you want and walk right out and
the cameras track everything you do they
bought Whole Foods the plan is to
implement this at Whole Foods that's why
they're doing the hand Palm the the Palm
scanner thing Whole Foods during the
pandemic I went in and I tried to get
them to make me a sandwich and they said
no they can't make me a sandwich because
of the stupid arbitrary garbage rules
and uh they were like no but we have
sandwiches made here and I was like
didn't you make those and they're like
yeah I'm like okay so you can make a
sandwich with your coveted germs wrap it
up in plastic and put it here
but and I could buy that but you can't
make a sandwich now and wrap it up in
plastic and hand it to me so that I have
the sandwich I want and the thing is
that no matter what else can
check it out and we won't stop can't
stop won't stop but the thing is that no
matter how bad you don't want it it's
gonna happen and the reason is people
are lazy awful and the problem with
Society is this is very simple the
problem with Society is we're too
comfortable
and people are willing to blindly comply
because they have AC they have heat
they're able to pay their bills they can
go grab a coffee from Starbucks when
they want and as long as they can do
those things they will gladly hand their
rights over to the government well I
gotta tell you man look look I know I'm
not a big fan of Starbucks well let's be
honest that pistachio cold brew cream
thing that's so good I haven't tried it
man I was thinking the other night that
you got to do uncomfortable things to
succeed and I thought no that's
backwards it's that if the things that
you need to do to succeed are
uncomfortable so you got to be willing
not everything that's uncomfortable is
going to make you succeed like don't
break your legs no I disagree I disagree
with someone with that you're you are
right but here's let me rephrase it
I think what happens to our society is
that what what used to be a rewarding
experience
people don't have to do and now hate
doing so for example exercise right
I like skating it feels good exercise is
is is is ancillary it's like it just so
happens that if you're skating you're
staying in shape but skating is fun yeah
there are a lot of people who like
working out because they're pushing
their limits and they're trying to get
more lift more weights but for a lot of
people most people working out sucks and
they're like I have to do something that
that's uncomfortable if I want to
succeed it's like it shouldn't be that
way it should be from when you're a kid
your parents take you out to go exercise
and it becomes a routine that you enjoy
doing that you push yourself and you
succeed at it and it feels good to do
those things you know what I mean it
used to be like biking is great
acquiring food used to be like that it
used to be a big deal when someone would
come back to the tribe with food yeah
that was like not expected if we don't
get it now it's like people love going
to the girl oh I don't want to do I have
to go all the way there to get the thing
like dude you are lucky I'm watching
1883 and there's the scene where the dad
is hunting with the kid and then he
points there right the scope at the deer
and then he tells the kid to look and
then the kid's five and he says you know
pull the trigger bigger and then then
he's like he brings the kid down and
he's like you did it you got your first
kill it's a deer it's gonna Feed Us for
weeks he's all excited and then he's got
to like gut it and pull out the garbage
and then throw on the horse and bring it
back or really carries it I think well
we you know what we don't even have to
go back to the 1800s I was actually
ironically just thinking about this
yesterday
and in the 90s you know in early 90s
when when I was growing up as a kid I
ate like
but when I joined the military at 17
years old I was 130 pounds why because
it wasn't as comfortable as it is today
to be in the house TV sucked you had to
get up and change the TV and everything
that you wanted to do if you wanted to
interact with your friends you had to go
outside we were it was so I truly
believe that of course food is an issue
I mean there's no doubt about that but I
believe the bigger issue is the
inactivity and and I think it proves it
because you know in the 90s we had a we
had the same foods that we had today and
uh and it was just as shitty but the
Obesity wasn't as rampant because we
were doing things we weren't sitting in
a dark room playing video games or
sitting at our phone and just our
friends are just at our disposal right
here on our phones we had to actually go
outside and interact with them you used
to have to go to the store to shop and
go to the bank to get money now I I
bought like 20 things on Amazon in the
last four or five days from my room I
didn't even leave the room yeah I
remember when I was a kid I'd have to go
run errands with my stepmom like before
the weekend and one of the errands was
always to go get cash because you
couldn't get any cash at the weekend or
you'd have to like go to the grocery
store and cash a check you have to stand
in line with everybody else who forgot
to go to the bank on Friday before the
debit card I got my first debt there was
no ATM we had to like do a drive through
with like a little hydraulic
thing and you whatever you had to
interact with somebody cash a check to
get your money I mean I think you're
completely right that the lack of
socialization is driving this also the I
think that the opiates are heavily
involved with the lack of socialization
but oh no doubt about that I mean but
the bottom line is it goes back to we're
just way too comfortable in today's
society and uh and and the video that I
uh that I filmed live when those police
officers came into my restaurant and
stripped my livelihood from me
that's the message I was trying to get
across to them I was not ragging on
police I've always supported you know
police officers uh what I was telling
them is what they specifically were
doing was wrong and I don't give a damn
what your profession is if you're a
police officer if you're a teacher uh if
you're in the military if you're a small
business owner if you're complicit in
stripping a citizen of their
constitutional rights you are wrong but
they were willing to do it and and I
know for a fact
that at least one of those officers that
they felt bad about what he did because
he had a friend come into my restaurant
afterwards and tell me such
and uh
but the reason he did it is because what
because he didn't want to lose his job
because he he wanted to maintain his
benefits and he wanted to have a
paycheck coming in so he can provide for
his family and on one hand you ask
yourself well can you blame him but then
on the other hand the answer is well the
only reason this is going on is because
of people like him that are willing to
be complicit in things that are illegal
and unconstitutional to be comfortable
now if every police officer involved in
that situation would have stood up and
said this is unconstitutional I'm not
doing it then it wouldn't have happened
and it was the same for me it would have
been way easier for me to comply and
just go along with uh what they were
telling me to do and I wouldn't have
lost you know six figures I wouldn't
have had the stress put on me in my
family that was put on me but there's
more there's things that are bigger than
you and there's things that are more
important than you and your business and
your money and my mindset was always if
I lose everything if everybody in this
entire country stands against me for
what I'm about to do and I lose it all
well I'm a hard worker I'll bust my ass
in in one way or another I'll provide
for my family and I'll be okay but if I
give up my freedoms I'll never get that
back and that's what I want people to
understand and remember next time is
that
if you if you refuse to stand up and
fight for what's right just so you can
keep the the comfortability the
comfortability of uh of your daily life
then you're going to lose something much
greater and those are your
constitutional rights and those are your
freedoms and and I just don't know how
to get that across to people but I hope
that my story and my situation I hope
that if nothing else what it proves is
that if you do stand up and you do fight
the people will rally behind you and you
can beat the government and you will
beat the government and and we are
bigger than the government we are
stronger than the government because we
are the government well and once you
give away your rights like that's your
kids rights too that's your
grandchildren's rights and that's the
most important thing you know then you
have to like fight a war to get them
back that's right yep and and I I did
this
I took on this fight mainly for my kids
and for the Next Generation because if
we don't
you and me if all of us here in this
room if if our generation doesn't step
up and and take this fight on right now
and not only take it on but when
and we just hand this fight over to the
next Generation by the time they're old
enough to fight this it'll be too far
gone will not be squashed already
exactly I got a feeling the next round
of shutdown government stuff is going to
be for power outages I could be wrong
what do you mean for power the grid goes
down for two weeks then our phones are
off people are trying to figure it out
the the government starts coming around
saying we're going to take control don't
leave the house don't leave the house
don't leave the house they're not going
to do that until they make us all have
electric cars they're going to wait till
we all have electric cars then we can't
go anywhere either I don't know if
they're gonna cause it or if it's just
gonna happen but if that's a situation
where it's like don't leave the house
don't leave the house what do we do or
do we resist again
literally how every single city was in
the during it's going to be asymmetrical
so next time it probably won't be a
virus next time it'll probably be
something a little they're calling it a
cyber cyber eleven yeah they're working
on that too like the FAA the flights
that all got grounded they're gonna they
could pull something well at the world
economic Forum they're referring to it
as a cyber pandemic or some kind of
cyber 911 incident that
it would wipe out everybody's money
right what are those things that would
like wipe out all of the information
temporarily
do you think that people should prepare
like realistically like I'm I've got
like a ham radio
um solar panels hey hey hey
everybody who listens to this show and
can or or figure out how to get chickens
is laughing right now listen to the show
because they got eggs and and their
neighbors are probably like please uh
might I borrow some extra pancakes and
you're like no they're mine actually you
can have some no you're you're not wrong
you're absolutely right I mean being
being self-sustainable is the most
important thing but I'm telling you guys
right now and um
I hope this doesn't come across as two
politicians but I am running for office
right now but I am the furthest thing
even in this room from a politician man
but I'm telling you guys you need you
need to start paying attention to State
politics these Federal elections are not
where you make your money it's at the
state level in Virginia in 2035
electric cars
are going to be the law so you are no
longer California too and New York so
Virginia and Oregon and Washington
exactly and I think it's Montana Wyoming
that said Wyoming said that they're
banning electric exactly electric cars
are banned yeah and so let me tell you
guys something that's where you're going
to move next a lot of people don't know
yeah I'm not absolutely it's awesome
it's expensive though yeah it is the
most important thing guys the most
important thing by far and and even if
you don't believe that you know and we
were talking about this before the show
even if you don't believe that any
election was stolen or any of that
elections are not secure in the state of
Virginia you can go vote without showing
an ID you tell me how elections are
secure when you get that's true in New
York too you just sign for it well hold
on in what was the story uh I think we
talked about it did we talk about it
non-citizens can vote oh yeah well in
New York they put up a proposal where
non-citizens could vote in local
elections and it was uh overturned they
can vote right now I'm going to tell you
how and not a lot of people know this so
check this out in the state of Virginia
and in many other states as well
uh as an illegal alien
as an illegal immigrant you can get a
driver's license at the DMV a valid
driver's license right so our voter
rolls they come from the DMV and they go
so how our voter rolls get handed down
Auto register right that's what happened
in California so check this out big
story a few years ago the people that
that run our voter rolls is an
organization called Eric e-r-i-c and
everybody look this up if you think I'm
bsing
e-r-i-c the electronic registration
information center Eric so what Eric
does is it reaches down to the DMVs and
it says Hey DMV we want all of your
information from all of your all of the
people in your state that are of legal
aids to vote so the DMV sends them all
that information now illegal immigrants
are in that batch because if you look in
the bylaws of Eric it doesn't hide it
from you it says in the bylaws of Eric
it says Hey DMV you are not allowed to
tell us who is the citizen and who's not
why I'll tell you why okay and so what
happens is Eric sifts through that
information it sends the the voter's
role the voter rolls down to the state
level and it says these are this is
everybody in your state that are allowed
that's allowed to vote and uh illegal
immigrants are included in that and the
answer to you as to why you know who
funded Eric who helped create Eric no
take a while yes George Soros George
Soros so George Soros is running your
elections and if you think any of that
is a lie please do the research thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time